Hi, this is the Lee Detective Agency We
will
accept any request If necessary, we will
carry packages,
investigate undercover
, and mediate disputes.
It's an exception, but that's the job of the police,
so are
n't you wearing a swimsuit from a detective drama
?  But what can I do
foryou
[music]
[music] It's been a
long time
Why are you here
so long?
I heard you work at this office
and came to see me
Who told
you that
?  Are you serious? You
're just a wind
Why aren't there cold medicines in the office?
I can't do
it, you can take this food
home The cost of taking it home is just one theory
[music]
Huh,
my head is still sleeping in the hospital
Who did
it?  Lend me a hand,
I can still do
it. If you appear in front of me, I'll definitely turn you in to the
police
.
Please take a look at this flower, it's
beautiful, isn't it? It's just like me
.
It is said that the authorities will ensure the normal operation of medical institutions and
the smooth supply of medical services, and ensure that medical
equipment and personnel are ready to respond immediately
.
It's been a long time since I came back to Ronmen and
I wanted to eat your hand cooking again
[music]
[music]  ]
Shall we have fish tonight
Goldfish aren't meant to be eaten
[laughing]
This
hat is what I got when I ran away I look
like an idiot with a rash so
I don't want you either I gotta have
dinner
[music]  ]